good morning Hank it's Tuesday so
earlier this morning I was kayaking on
the White River and I came to an island
that only exists when the water is lone
so I had to choose which stream to
follow down and I thought as I always do
in these situations of Robert Frost poem
the road not taken' you know the one
that ends with two roads diverged in a
yellow wood and I I took the one less
traveled by and that has made all the
difference so I followed the road that
seemed a less obvious choice it turns
out that there was less obvious for a
reason so Hank the road not taken' is an
interesting poem because one it's kind
of responsible for the death of the
person it was written for and to what
most people conclude from the poem is
the exact opposite of what Robert Frost
intended for people to conclude and also
three this dissonance points it's
something great and terrible about
poetry I think Hank but let's start with
one the Dead Guy so Robert Frost was
inspired to write this poem by the many
walks he took with his friend the
English poet edward thomas thomas was a
very obsessive and indecisive person and
every time they'd come to a fork in the
road he wouldn't know which one to take
you know like how if you're in the
english countryside and you choose the
wrong path you might get eaten by a lion
but you can't know that until after
you've made the choice i assume that
there are lines in england at least
dandelions and in Frost's mine the poem
was like gently mocking people who
obsess over the importance of tiny
little decisions right but as often
happens with people who are mocked to
gently Edward Thomas didn't get the joke
and took the poem very very seriously
and so even though Edward Thomas was too
old to be expected to enlist he went
ahead and took the road less traveled
joining the British Army to fight in
World War one whereupon he was promptly
shot through the chest and killed since
then hey pretty much everyone including
me has adopted Edward Thomas's
interpretation of the poem despite the
fact that it you know it killed him I
think there's just something really
alluring about the idea that choosing
the road less traveled is always a good
idea it would be very helpful if there
were some overarching guideline like
follow the path that others don't also
following the road less taken as the
added advantage of making everyone feel
like a nonconformist which is nice but
of course there are a bunch of problems
for one thing if everyone follows the
road less traveled it quickly becomes
the road more traveled furthermore there
are many times when the road
travelled is more traveled for a reason
because for instance the road less
traveled leads to a kayak unfriendly
Marsh or because it turns out that
there's something kind of nice about
having a spouse and two kids in a
minivan anyway Hank I've been thinking
about this a lot because over at our
podcast dear Hank and John we've been
getting a lot of questions from
listeners who are making huge life
decisions you know should I go into the
military which college should I attend
should I attend college at all as humans
we constantly have to make all of these
big big decisions with very limited
information I think we're both
incredibly blessed to have great
marriages and great spouses but I had no
idea what I was agreeing to on my
wedding day I thought I was saying I
want to be in a romantic relationship
with you for the rest of my life I did
not realize that I was also saying like
I want to be co-ceos of a company that
raises children and mows lawns and stuff
anyway Hank the other thing about dear
Hank and John is that I insist on
beginning each episode with a short poem
and joy in the last few weeks we've had
a bunch of discussions about poetry
weather poetry matters what poetry does
etc and I think if we have the road not
taken' one answer about what poetry can
do because poetry is so often musical
and rhythmic it has a way of sticking in
our heads like I've memorized it almost
by accident Bross thought the poem was
exploring how people experienced choice
making rather than offering advice but
precisely because it sounds good Hank
it seems like good advice and even
though I know that it isn't good advice
at least not consistently I suspect that
the next time I am facing a fork in the
road or a fork in the river
those iambic feet will wander back into
my mind and I will once again be biased
however minutely toward the road less
traveled I guess that's one example of
how I think poetry can really matter in
the real lives of real people Hank and
why I think that poets and readers alike
need to be very careful with language
after all Hank we don't want to end up
like Edward Thomas but we also don't
want to end up like the poet who at
least in a roundabout way killed him
Hank I'll see you on Friday